it was a holiday to celebrate the end of
British rule and the creation of
Pakistan in 1947 but 72 years on their
slogans of freedom remain just that
insufferable
the capital of Kashmiri territory
administered by Pakistan there's
mounting anger against the effective
annexation of indian-administered
Kashmir and frustration on the Pakistani
side of the divided territory bah God
nubium this situation would be resolved
with words the solution is in action we
stand behind Pakistani army the
Pakistani government has suspended trade
and transport links as well as
downgrading diplomatic ties but Kashmiri
these measures don't satisfy us Indian
forces have besieged Kashmir ease for
the last 10 days their lives are in
danger we want Pakistan to take
practical measures an army can only be
expelled by another army Kashmir ease
have made enough sacrifices government
leaders in Islamabad are being pressured
by both opposition politicians and
Kashmiri
to back their words with action Prime
Minister Imran Khan arrived in Mazar
Abad with a message of solidarity and a
promise to do all he can he compared
India's ruling Hindu nationalist BJP
with Nazis and said Muslims worldwide
are looking to the United Nations to
stop India violating basic rights Hahn
accused India of an anti-muslim
demographic shift and for the first time
since the crisis began shared Pakistani
intelligence reports information we have
information and we have had to National
Security Committee meetings the Pakistan
Army has full knowledge that India has
made a plan to take action in Azad Jammu
Kashmir like the action they took in
Bala costs after parma according to our
information they have made a more
sinister plan now the army is prepared
not just the army but the entire nation
will fight alongside our military
Prime Minister Imran Khan says it will
be his responsibility to take the
message of Kashmiri student in a tional
community Pakistan has already asked for
an emergency session of the UN Security
Council and while he was delivering that
message in the building behind me
Pakistanis across the country were
marking their Independence Day in
solidarity with Kashmiri
even the police decorated their patrol
cars with the Kashmiri flag alongside
Pakistan's people from all political
affiliations in the capital Islamabad
said they want to remind the world of
how India is abusing Kashmiri
PRO Kashmir independence slogans were
chanted in vizir Astana and rallies held
in tribal areas which used to be under
the control of Taliban a few years ago
and what's said to be the largest
Pakistani flag made this year along with
the slogan that says Kashmir will become
Pakistan many of these people are the
descendants of tribal fighters who
helped the military take control of what
is now Pakistan administered Kashmir
Pakistan insists that there is no other
solution than diplomacy but many
Pakistanis who took to the streets feel
otherwise Osama bin Jawad al Jazeera was
Afra bod pakistan-administered Kashmir